Director
of the CIA, Bill Burns,
says he is confident
that China is considering
giving lethal aid to Russia.
How soon
do you believe
China could actually start
providing that assistance?
Well, first,
thanks for having me on, Dana.
The other thing
that Director Burns, Bill
Burns of the CIA said
was that we haven't seen them do it yet.
We actually haven't seen them
take a final decision
to provide the aid to Russia,
and we haven't seen the aid
be provided to Russia.
So we will watch carefully.
We will be vigilant
and we will continue
to send a strong message
that we believe that sending military aid
to Russia
at this time
when they are using their weapons
to bombard cities, kill civilians,
and commit atrocities,
would be a bad mistake.
And China should want no part of it.
If China does go ahead
and give the lethal support
that your intelligence shows
they're considering giving to Russia.
Can you please be specific
about how the U.S. would respond
Well, again,
you're talking
about a hypothetical situation
because at present,
China has not moved forward
as far as we can discern.
We have not seen them do it.
And I would prefer to keep our messages
to China on this question,
what the consequences would be
in the private,
high level
diplomatic channels
that we have established
to discuss these issues.
Secretary Blinken
saw China's
top diplomat, Wang
Yi, just a few days ago in Munich.
They had a detailed conversation
on this subject.
Secretary Blinken laid out the U.S.
position in perspective.
And I'm going to leave
that important and grave
set of conversations around the stakes
of China
coming in behind Russia
and their war in Ukraine
for behind closed doors.
So just to be clear,
you don't want to say it now
on international television,
but the consequences
if in fact, China does
this have been very directly
and specifically communicated to China
privately
President Biden has made clear
in previous reflections on this issue,
because this is not a new issue.
We have been dealing with the question
of whether China might be right.
But you said this was her trip to Russia
going back to the beginning
of the conflict. Right.
The point I was making, Dana,
is just
that President Biden has said previously,
we're not just making direct threats.
We're just laying out
both the stakes and the consequences,
how things would unfold.
And we are doing that
clearly and specifically behind
closed doors.
How concerned just kind of look at this
big picture.
How concerned
are you about these two major U.S.
adversaries working together
on the battlefield in Ukraine
and what that means
sort of more generally about
the relationships here
Well, look, the U.S.
position in
this conflict is straightforward.
We're not going to stand by
and allow one country
to roll over another country
and try to wipe it off the map.
And we're going to build
and have built a coalition
of more than 50 nations
to resist that and help
the Ukrainians
defend their own territory.
China's position in
this is much more awkward.
In fact,
there was just a vote at the U.N.
General Assembly
in which China abstained.
They did not vote with Russia.
They were one of a number of countries
that just tried to stand on the sidelines
when China talks rhetorically
about the war in Ukraine.
They tie themselves into knots
because they know that going
all in with Russia in this war in Ukraine
would alienate
a substantial
number of countries that they are working
hard to maintain good relations with.
So from our perspective, actually,
this war presents real complications for
Beijing and
Beijing will have to make its
own decisions
about how it proceeds,
whether it provides military assistance.
But if it goes down
that road,
it will come at real cost to China.
And I think China's leaders are weighing
that as they make their decisions.
President Zelensky
is still asking the U.S.
for F-16 fighter jets,
but President
Biden said on Friday
that Ukraine doesn't need the F-16s.
Now, I know you said that Ukraine doesn't
have the training
and the maintenance capacity
to use the jets,
but is the real reason
you're not giving Ukraine these jets
because you're trying to balance
how far to go in
supporting Ukraine
without antagonizing Russia too much
The real reason, Dana,
is that we are taking a very hard
look at what it is
that Ukraine needs for the immediate
phase of the war that we're in.
In this phase of the war requires tanks,
infantry fighting
vehicles, armored personnel
carriers, artillery,
tactical air defense systems,
so that Ukrainian fighters
can retake territory
that Russia currently occupies.
F-16s are a question for a later time.
And that's why
President Biden said that for now,
he's not moving forward with those.
So as far as we're concerned, the U.S.
effort has got to be to get Ukraine
the tools
it needs for the mission at hand.
And the mission at hand
is to have a successful counter
offensive where Ukraine is able
to take back its own territory
away from the hands of the Russians.
So you're not ruling out giving
Ukraine the F-16s at a later time?
What President
Biden said is
what goes across the administration.
And he was very clear.
He said, I'm ruling them out for now.
Got it.
I want to ask about Crimea.
Today marks exactly
nine years since Russia
illegally annexed Crimea.
The Biden administration
still repeatedly
says that Crimea is part of Ukraine.
You also say that Ukraine gets to define
what victory look looks like.
So why don't you just sort of give a yes
or no answer to this?
If Ukraine decided
that victory means recapturing
Crimea militarily
with the United States support, that
Dan, I can't give a yes
or no
answer to
what is a hypothetical question
right now.
What President Zelensky is focused on
is getting into the best
possible position on the battlefield
so that he can be
in the best possible position
at the negotiating table.
And he spoke as recently
as this week about diplomacy.
We want to help Ukraine
turn battlefield gains
into diplomatic leverage.
And that requires us
to give them the military assistance
they need to make those gains.
What ultimately happens
with Crimea in the context of this war
and a settlement of this war
is something for the Ukrainians
to determine
with the support of the United States.
But I'm just not going
to get into hypothetical questions,
because what we're facing today
is a counteroffensive
in the east, in the south,
that we need
to give them the tools to fight.
And we are doing that.
You know, you're talking
about supporting Ukraine
and you're
talking about them
taking the lead
on how they define victory,
which is understandable. It's their war.
But the administration
is also promising them
that America will support them
as long as it takes.
Can you level with the American people
about what expectations should be?
Could there still be a full blown war
going on a year
from now
on the second anniversary
that the US
is still supporting at the levels
it is now
I can level
with the American people in saying
that war is unpredictable.
One year ago,
we were all bracing for the fall of Kiev
in the matter in a matter of days.
One year later,
Joe Biden was standing
with President
Zelensky in Kiev,
declaring The Kiev stands.
So I cannot predict the future
and nor can anyone else.
And anyone
who is suggesting
they can define for you
how and when this war will end
is not leveling with the American people
or anyone else.
What I can say
is that the United States
is going to continue to marshal
this wide international coalition
of countries
to provide Ukraine
with the tools that it needs
to defend itself.
And to take back territory
that the Russians have occupied.
And we are prepared to do that.
We have the staying power for that.
We have proven we can sustain unity.
We have proven
that we can sustain this level of effort.
And President Biden
went to Key to indicate that our support
will be unwavering.
Before I let you go,
I want to ask about a new Wall Street
Journal report out this morning
that a classified intelligence report
from the Department
of Energy
concludes that the coronavirus pandemic
most likely did not emerge naturally,
but it did come from a laboratory leak.
Did the coronavirus
pandemic start in a lab?
Is that what you believe now?
Well,
Dana, there is
a variety of views
in the intelligence community.
Some elements
of the intelligence community
have reached conclusions on one side,
some on the other.
A number of them have said
they just don't have enough information
to be sure.
Here's what I can tell you.
President Biden has directed repeatedly
every element
of our intelligence community
to put effort and resources behind
getting to the bottom of this question.
And one of the things
in that Wall Street Journal report,
which I can't confirm or deny,
but I will say the reference
to the Department of Energy,
President Biden
specifically requested
that the national labs,
which are part of the Department
of Energy,
be brought into this assessment
because he wants to put every tool
at use
to be able
to figure out what happened here.
And if we gain
any further insider information,
we will share it with Congress
and we will share it
with the American people.
But right now,
there is not a definitive answer
that has emerged from the intelligence
community on this question.